you
and here we go simple as that under five
have 33 at the moment let's see what
more we get
we've played
what is 97 about
huh
that night's going to have to take
another step yeah
hello you gon queenside I guess
it's already
as if my pony has already castled in
that direction
[Music]
take with the night
let's see what do we want to go do I
have any tactic
I'm gonna try this it's gotta be pretty
scary yeah that Bishop cutting in this
is a difficult pin to get out of I like
the security for my king and queen here
next and that Knight is a goner multiple
pins right
and this one's oh I didn't I didn't see
that idea isn't this a slick move might
be a slick move
hmm
let's just double up
yeah I have the time - oh my goodness
I'm even see that either
is this working
looking for a queen to be 8 I'm down on
the clock a bishop here I could take on
this square
is actually a cool start to this game
taking advantage of that pin
work out all those details but I did
like that Bishop knifing in there that
King position
kinda reminding me of the Horowitz
bishops
and do I really mean that no like some
kind of bottons me
anyhow off to a good start Game one
race next opponent
or break first in the center okay let's
just build up slow and steady I need
some more support here
yeah let's see if we get the bishop
param I guess we got it
just going to centralise forgot I was
even throwing a threat against h3
let's have it open up just a hair
and I have this covered
I grabbed that pond threatening d-3 she
actually pretty difficult to defend to
go in reverse
and I think I'm just winning upon here
okay I think now I'll actually go for a
pawn grab
I don't see anything wrong with that
here
okay let's get the rook doing something
exciting there's a lot of pieces around
here
the bishop away and is actually not a
threat I do have the bishop here it's
easy to miss maybe they take
just want to consolidate a little bit I
want to try and get rid of their the
aggressive pieces first and then maybe
go into pacman mode really down on the
clock
think g4 is necessary Bishop here
there's this yes they just missed the
lateral movement
trying to get out of that pen
[Laughter]
love answers okay with giving some
material you know they're gonna you know
they're down on time they they are that
excuse me they resigned
okay I'm not sure it was that the first
time I played that opponent ever
I didn't know
but the cross-table was
but uh anyhow that's a that's an
important win because that was the top
dog
got a quick win in there
first couple games
already going fishing here hey this is a
first-time opponent and that's
definitely a blunder because of a pin er
oniy
f3
beginning
Queens going down no need to go fishing
in this one
all right back determine where we're in
they're here I mean 60 players are on
board
Orbitz is in paws mode hopefully returns
all right Hanna Jia
first time opponent another
opponent
these are these are a blast alright
we're gonna take care my opponent do not
want to
establish a pond in the center so what
is that light square bishop going to do
better castle now no will you ever
castle now that well we're gonna we're
gonna try and cause some problems here
with this dark square bishop I want to
put it into D Wow
fancy all right he's here to stay
and now I want to meet c5 with the d5
we're going to be a centralizing machine
um let's actually go for this little
reposition so that's how they're working
it okay well what we're opening up now
on the rope I have a queen check this is
killer clean esta block and then I take
the rook probably resign here and now do
I have anything fancy
let's return here
Kings not going anywhere
and what's this night up to I'm not
gonna let that night hurt us any how
about we just take them out and then get
here this rook is just not playing
- now yeah big trouble here clean back
check and then a rook here next for me
Queen must block alright taking
advantage of pins already 20 minutes to
go who was first seven minutes flew by
what's up check yourself in the chat
who's throwing a couple pigs my way
piggy mounts are out there tone-deaf is
uh tone-deaf in the chat is saying
Pinner Oney is my favorite pizza topping
you know what I have to agree I am I am
a fan of pepperoni
as well
actually you could take that pun right
it's thinking I had enough support for
this not quite isn't this a bit of a
stranded stranded piece these pieces are
all very very misplaced like where's
that night going
nobody knows he's going back home
we're going to try for some pom sack
and there's probably a better way that
could have approached this but okay
we're going to centralize and hunt down
this pawn and complete development
there is that move
all right we're going to take there
I just want to give my opponent some
direction
how greedy is my opponent you're gonna
take there it's that move about wow this
is a greedy opponent holy cow I did not
see that one
I still think that I could trade Queens
and have something interesting
there was a better way so greedy I can't
believe how greedy my opponent is
take my truck first
okay could I could I maybe get at the
king here
yeah this one isn't this isn't how you
should how you should do it
hmm and I'm down on the clock
ah man after that start
that move oh this one's not gonna end
well down on the clock in position yeah
this one's this one's busted
I should throw in the towel with whoa
let's then a left drunk right now slap
me around I don't know what kind of
opening that was but it definitely add
me rattled and it shouldn't have it
wasn't objectively good but yeah you
gotta you gotta be able to punish it and
guess who didn't punish it
okay
get back on the horse and try and take
advantage of this guy each pawn loves
running
when there's a night on g6
so oh that's what this was actually am a
trap and take you're too soon
hey what about the dark squares I wonder
about those just a hair
whoo fancy night here Queen takes Knight
very slick
nice mash through here yet let's make
use of this square that's the square
that was given up on my opponents last
move or with my opponents last move
centralized on a castle by hand I want
to keep this tension around run this
Knights struggling hmm
have anything good here
yes I'll just return real quick I'm
flushing me back
it was like it's close to mate yeah 9 H
6 9 f 6 you know let's sent let's
centralized here my night loves this
square I don't think that this diagonal
can open up so again let's defend my
night
now I'll go king - king - f2
I'll block I'm okay with the in exchange
I'm still better because of the minor
pieces this is a big dummy
ooh miss that the Queen was there
I'm up the exchange
and that's good enough and on the clock
as well
so it'll take guys quick though
yeah I should know this guy is
definitely quick
okay I'm gonna hunt that pond down if
Bush I have that I got a little bit too
close all right
stana mer thank you for the 14 months in
a row any others that I may have missed
I will certainly address that at the end
of the tournament what's up slim mg in
the chat John Matt it's throwing out the
flag emote yes a lot of flags in Bullitt
yeah we'll take upon that's a big pond
center pond
and I don't care about my C pawn in this
case
maybe this was I went to put my knight
there
okay this is still fine them up a piece
or up upon
I guess we'll take because I do not want
to be opposite the rook and take the
knight out
a lot of centralizing
be too tough to defend well nots
indirectly defended in here I can't take
the night because of that shot that
would hurt I want this night doing
something can I scare the Queen away
let's offer a queen exchange night here
the Queen could back up even though I
had pressure oh now this is a nice one I
have this King Knight around
you know let's just consolidate a little
bit
inch my queen in there
so here and out of pens
okay now this is a really nice square
okay this is this is a rock that my
opponent probably wanted this square for
the knight or the bishop so just flush
them away
after queen exchanges
uh right here puts pressure on a lot of
stuff and let's get let's keep running
with this can't take twice here I get
the night in the end I thought at least
not getting hurt em I don't think so
even with a push I should be alright
it's getting a little bit too scary also
I'm down on the clock
yeah I'm actually way down on a clock
or seconds
you
[Music]
oh my god
you
Hey okay that was ugliness ah I don't
know where my time is going well what
had me thinking there oh you know when
their queen got active and started being
opposite my king and putting me in pins
they weren't how difficult to get out of
but apparently it was taking me quite a
bit of time to sort out those those pins
mmm d4 let's try that
this was ugly do I really want to give
up my dark square bishop we're gonna see
how to play down a dark square bishop Oh
God
this is bad
I don't know what is what is going on
with me here it's night is a killer he's
worth seven points at least
Oh God
yeah
oh god that's already a game ender isn't
it
or is it oh my god I just want a piece
maybe now there's Bishop here
they don't see Bishop g5 don't see
Bishop g5 you saw Bishop g5
oh yeah just Rick takes Rick oh god that
was horrible
I don't know why I didn't capture on d4
twice or I can't explain it the cap is
in there and he is clearly gone berserk
80% berserk right mmm okay I'm still
surprisingly in the hunt even though
there was a zero to two zero that's not
a good stretch
professor Warren strim
am i doing
but these pronunciations bad as usual
I'm sure
okay
and a focus and we're will go for this
see if white go
Ford with a minority attack
first getting a tempo and then challenge
the bishop so here we go with the b4
[Music]
um yeah not sure what to do here
ninety-seven
comes b5 okay
is going to be very difficult to defend
there's that move yeah I'm in a I'm in a
giant Paul oh well I'm just down upon
and clearly worst at the end of all
these
oh man
tough day at the office for me after
work some serious magic here and I don't
think there's going to be serious magic
Kings a fighter watch out he's extra
slippery when I'm down a boatload of
pawns Yeah right
my kidding
I get made it so I break them up well I
got a pun is the serious magic nearby I
have a passer see how fast he could run
my opponent nervous give a check go here
let's do that first
try like this I need to get active
not behind that pond at least
you
oh my god I almost pulled off some
serious magic oh man they had less than
a second oh that would have been amazing
if I could've did it on the clock ah
that minority attack I don't know if I
should be playing that opening it's too
easy for black
it's one of those where you're just kind
of target practice and I was target
practice there
I had a babysitter yeah a half-dead pawn
that backward guy never wanted to do
that okay let's focus here that's a pond
and okay I was thinking about this queen
h5 but there's a knight f6 but what
about nine f6 now it's try Knight f6 now
Knight f6 I could back up then where
does my knight go I had this as well if
you're wondering couldn't he have just
played 96 absolutely
already um right here this is a good one
I take here and then if clean f7 okay
we're opening things up Oh didn't see
that one
that was a nice in-betweener I must say
I am on this night though so there's no
time to address the recapture running
for I ah we take you right away taking
the rook the knight recaptures okay I
think I think we're in the driver's seat
here
yeah let's jump in
and next we'll we'll get rid of the
night going here I guess there's a fancy
check
okay LightSquared Bishop you need to do
something okay we got this one
put some phones on on light squares and
then run
alright where's the main plenty of time
to
plenty time to do it here and then upon
me okay
I'll take it whoo all right well hold
the top dog oh and this is a very low
rating for him oh that's not fair
2182 but he is in berserk mode so take a
pun
all right let's let's see if we could
attack
still a little bit mm-hmm really lining
up some some
and fancy here
all right
I don't know in which direction I want a
castle
hmm
I'm chewing up a lot of time
this is scary
oh they went there
just do these kind of moves
okay there is a there's a pin against my
night but I have a pin as well against
their king
oh I wasted so much time there
hmm
Oh God
12 seconds to 41
man we're getting smoked in this game
big-time oh boy
yeah this is this is a gonner just
rippling up on that night ouch
ah man night
for Knight g5 collet yeah that night was
a killer um yeah
that was painful
Kings Indian on board let's grab some
space
why not mm-hmm you're gonna they're
gonna go here I want I want to keep some
pieces on the board and actually the
nice the Knights dead I should know that
a little bit sooner yeah he's he's ever
thought of squares so he's taking
somebody down first
not going out of the game without a
fight there's less than five minutes
left in this tournament
move
let's let's throw that in first on the
Queen Shack clean trade let's pick
something up
now let's take
in the end I have something what oh my
god
please land a fork I think I have a fork
by force no not quite
all right I still have material I don't
know what I was what I was thinking
there
check-check no no I don't think I have
it
want to consolidate
as well
of answers I hope you're not here
looking for answers they are nowhere to
be found
it's one of them it's one of those
tournaments let's get a flight square
and hope my opponent runs out of fuel I
only have eight ticks left oh man
I need a phone a friend big time
I'm burn out
Oh God 28 27 23 I have 20 I'm fishing
for a 4 and it's a long way huh um okay
let's see if we get finished with a win
or two I'm just hoping for one win one
at a time
okay
uh-uh okay let's go here
and force 96
and I believe also forced this captures
otherwise I take here I thought okay am
I missing
ah I want to go with just a solid
structure but my night on a secure
square and all right this is this is
good for me I am up upon but I'm playing
with how confidence
okay
I think I was ready to make a bad move
there
is it okay now it might have been some
tactical shot on d4 it's going to return
Oh fancy stuff on h2 Inbetweeners
just trade stay central from here what
would I like to have happen charades
mm-hmm or trades
flush that night away
clean clothes too trapped isn't she
take on this square
push
let's try something else
okay night on c5 I think that's what I
want Knight on d6
come on two points the rook
in the center now
giving up some squares with that move
the Queen doing
just dropped a rook chapter look again
oh my goodness
not my finest display here chess
Oh God
you
oh god awful oh man and that's gonna be
the last one that was not a good showing
at all especially to end the tournament
Oh
ugliness
sincerity rules I could not I could not
find a trade in that one at all being up
upon
good games all ah awfulness
let's see what I'm even going to finish
barely on page one let's see noid oh
please don't win a game not even in a
game I survived
I got page one barely Oh take peach one
with 2033 infers my first-round opponent
30:13 28 26 24 Wow
it was pretty close even though I had
how many losses 1 2 3 4 5 out of 13 whoo
was the what was my rating performance
2261
ah okay good games all
you